foreign
[Music]
we are here outside the house which was
set on fire by Israeli settlers
according to neighbors and eyewitnesses
in the village of terms the Israeli
settlers first set fire to this car and
then the fire turned into a full-blown
fire which damaged and devastated the
entrance of this house it could have
been a human tragedy had not been for
the help and support of locals in terms
Ayah who rushed to boot out the fire so
we had to come turn it off like we did
we tried our best to turn it off before
the firefighters come and glad we did
foreign
[Music]
ever since my childhood till now that
I'm 57 we've been living the nightmare
of settlers and their attacks which have
increased
just look North across the hills here
and you can see one of the Israeli
settlements and the Palestinians here
say the settlers are not Joy about their
main objective to seize more land and
make it harder for them to have their
own state
[Music]
foreign